Ринок землі, медицина по-новому,
штрафи за "євробляхи" та жодних російськомовних шкіл.
У 2020 році на українців чекає багато змін.
Головні з них - в огляді DW.
Вже із жовтня в Україні
після багаторічного мораторію
має відкритися ринок землі.
Її зможуть купувати українські громадяни і компанії.
Тоді як іноземці та іноземні корпорації,
як запевняє уряд,
зможуть зробити це лише за результатами всеукраїнського референдуму.
Після скасування мораторію на продаж сільськогосподарських земель
державна скарбниця, за прогнозами експертів,
поповнюватиметься завдяки
вищим цінам на оренду.
Якщо ж держава поетапно продаватиме цю землю,
це має принести
мільярдні надходження до бюджету.
У новому році в Україні стартує
другий великий етап медичної реформи.
Наразі держава вже оплачує медичні послуги
на рівні первинної ланки
за принципом "гроші ходять за пацієнтом".
Тобто українці звертаються до сімейного лікаря, педіатра або терапевта,
а їхні послуги оплачує держава
через Національну службу здоров'я.
З квітня нові правила фінансування запрацюють
і для спеціалізованої медичної допомоги.
Це найрізноманітніші медичні послуги -
від діагностики, пологів
і простих хірургічних втручань
до проведення складних операцій.
У листопаді-грудні 2020 року
відбудеться другий всеукраїнський
перепис населення України.
За практикою ООН, переписи населення проводяться раз на десять років.
В Україні перепис планувався ще з 2011 року,
але кілька разів переносився.
Очікується, що результати перепису стануть базою для реформи цифрової трансформації -
"країни в смартфоні", а також
для розрахунку бюджету
та інших важливих соціально-економічних показників.
У наступному навчальному році усі українські середні школи,
включно з приватними, мають перейти
на українську мову викладання.
Російську мову викладатимуть
лише факультативно.
Перехід розпочнеться у вересні 2020-го
і має повністю завершитися за три роки.
Школярам обіцяють надати
підручники українською мовою,
а викладачі зможуть пройти курс навчання української.
Нині в Україні залишилося близько двохсот шкіл
з російською мовою викладання.
Найбільше їх у Харківській, Запорізький, Одеській
та Дніпропетровській областях.
У Києві таких лише чотири.
З 1 січня нового року
і до кінця опалювального сезону
тариф на газ для споживачів буде фіксованим -
6 600 гривень за тисячу кубометрів.
Однак кінцева роздрібна ціна
на блакитне паливо в кожному регіоні
залежатиме від витрат на транспортування,
а також від націнки постачальників.
За нинішніх транспортних тарифів
кінцева роздрібна ціна
коливатиметься від 7,2 до 7,8 грн за кубометр газу.
У 2019-му це було 8,5 грн за кубометр,
тобто на 12 відсотків дорожче.
Тим, хто ввіз автомобіль в Україну
із порушенням митних правил,
із нового року доведеться платити штрафи.
Суми покарання чималі: за перевищення терміну перебування так званих "євроблях"
до 30 днів це 85 тисяч гривень.
Якщо довше - штраф у 170 тисяч гривень
або конфіскація.
Крім того, за використання нерозмитненого авто
в комерційних цілях
стягнуть іще 34 тисячі.
За найскромнішими оцінками,
нині українськими дорогами
все ще їздить понад 300 тисяч
нерозмитнених автівок з іноземною реєстрацією.
На новий рік покладають великі сподівання
і в питанні кардинальних змін ситуації на Донбасі.
Адже вже на березень-квітень запланована наступна зустріч лідерів "нормандської четвірки".
До цього часу радники лідерів України, Росії, Німеччини і Франції
та міністри закордонних справ цих країн
мають, серед іншого, напрацювати варіанти
проведення місцевих виборів на окупованому Донбасі,
а також забезпечити виконання
необхідних для цього
політичних та безпекових моментів.
Проте все залежатиме від того, чи погодиться на цю зустріч
російський президент Путін чи знову заморозить "нормандський" формат".